Remember I said earlier that if we have the equation of the probability density
function we can use calculus to find the area under the curve between any two
values or between negative infinity in any value. Mathematicians have put these
values in a table. Here is the top of this table, it gives you a little diagram
saying that when we have the z score, the values in this table tell us the
proportion less than that z score, in the standard normal curve. So this table
is for the standard normal distribution, and remember that's when the mean is
zero and the standard deviation is one. This way, after standardizing any normal
distribution. In other words after calculating the z scores for the values that
we're interested in, we can use this table to approximate the proportion less
than that particular z square. Here, the tenths place runs vertically and the
hundredths place runs horizontally. So if we have of a z score of say, negative
2.75. Remember, that would then be less than the mean. Negative 2.7 is here, and
0.05 is here. So if we follow over, these cells meet at .003. So the proportion
less than negative 2.75 is .003. Or .3%. So again that's the probability that we
get less than negative 2.75. And that's the proportion of objects in the sample
that have a score less than negative 2.75. There's a link to the z table that we
shared and so use that link when you use the z table which you are going to use
in the next quiz.